Rod's world hey what's going on guys
it's Rob and Lila wanted to join in the
movie as well as you can see I hope
you're having a good holiday break today
I'm going to show you how to make
something pretty cool and useful this
time of year and origami gift box and
you made one a little bit bigger than
the other one so you can fit them on top
of each other these work really well for
getting gifts this time of year as
you'll see I have a gift for you what is
it oh no way you can eat treats
contentment do you like the gift good
girl yeah you going to need two sheets
of paper you can use printer paper you
can use origami paper you can even use
newspaper or even gift wrap be creative
and have fun once you have the two
sheets you're ready to go to start off
if you're not using a square paper you
could take the top edge fold it across
so that it's lined up with the left side
make a crease along the bottom and then
you could tear the paper at that crease
if you're using origami paper you want
to have the colored side face up now
that we have a crease going this way I'm
going to take the upper left corner and
crease it across to the bottom right
corner
make crease on that edge and you can
open the paper and you'll see we have an
X take the top edge and fold it down to
the bottom edge once the edges are
nicely lined up then again you can make
a crease on the top edge here and of
course I like to make the creases with
my finger now open the paper up again
and then make a crease going the other
way
so now if you open up the paper you
should have an X and a plus in the
middle of the paper now we're going to
turn the paper over and I'm going to
take each of these corners and fold them
directly into the middle take the corner
of the paper fold it into the middle and
just make sure that both of these edges
line up with the creases that we have in
the paper once they're lined out you can
make a crease on the edge here
do the same with the other corners just
line it up like you would for an
airplane and then make a crease
so now you should have something that
looks like this we're going to turn the
model a little bit like that so that it
looks like a box now I'm going to take
the top edge and the bottom edge and
fold them directly on this horizontal
line here take it and fold it down and
when it's lined up you can make a crease
on the top do the same with the bottom
edge fold it and meet it up with the top
edge right at that middle line now you
can open both of those edges up and turn
it the other way take the top edge line
it up with the middle and then make the
crease might have to round the paper off
a little bit here if it's a little stiff
line it up and crease it on the bottom
alright guys so we're pretty much ready
to make the box now
so before we start I'm just going to
have you do a couple extra creases that
we have already in the paper so just
take these four tips in the middle and
just fold them up like this okay then
you can put them back in it flip it over
and we're just going to fold on these
two creases here so just fold here
especially in the corners here and also
going this way okay so now we could flip
it back over and we're going to open up
these two flaps of the paper so just
pull on them like that now I'm going to
take these two edges and I'm going to
put them back in the middle so right
along this crease just lift up these two
edges put them in the middle and just
give them a quick little push now we're
going to close the box and remember it's
a square so this is basically where
we're going to close it alright we're
going to bring it in sort of like that
so I'm just going to draw on a couple
creases here so you see what's happening
along them we're going to take this edge
right here and fold it inwards and it
should already have a crease on that
diagonal line there on these two folds
this is a valley fold this is a mountain
fold
so it's folded downwards here and it's
folded upwards here like that so just
take this little triangle here and push
it against the paper like that do the
same with this triangle just fold it on
this line fold it in and then what you
do just take your thumbs
and you can just push right in here
there you go so that's how you lift up
the edge of the box
and then all you need to do is to fold
right along this crease so this is the
flap we're going to fold it into the box
push right on this wall and this should
already have a crease here so you just
got to flatten it in and that's how you
put in the flap of the box to close it
let's do the same with the other side
again we're going to press right on this
crease and lift up the flap we could
bring these two edges right into the
middle and as you see if you push on
these two triangles the corners will
meet up in the middle and we can just
flip this right into the middle of the
box and give it a good crease along the
top here oops there goes down that's
okay and then all you need to do is to
pinch the corners of the box and there
you go you have made the base of the box
so the lid of the box is made the same
exact way as you could see in the paper
I have an X and I also have a plus I
flip the paper over and put all four
corners into the middle now at this
point I turn the paper and I'm going to
put these four edges next to the middle
line this time I'm not going to fold it
directly on top of the line I'm going to
leave a little bit of space maybe about
an eighth of an inch I'll take the top
edge fold it in next to that middle line
leaving a little bit of space right
about there should be good
and you might need to just round it off
on the corner here so there's the middle
line and there's the edge maybe about an
eighth of an inch do the same at the
bottom so you can see there's a little
space there left in the middle and then
do the same with the other two edges now
again open up all the edges and open
these two flaps push the two edges into
the middle of the paper tuck the corners
in and push on that crease and you can
use your thumbs to press and tuck the
flap into the middle of the box and then
crease on the top flip it around tuck
those two triangles in and then push and
lift with your thumbs tuck that flap in
and there you go there's the lid now all
you need to do is to fit them together
and you've completed your box I hope you
enjoyed the video if you did enjoy it
give it a thumbs up down below if you
guys want to see more be sure to hit the
subscribe button down below
I hope you have a wonderful holiday
season also if you guys did want to send
me anything not gifts necessarily but if
you have any origami or whatever you
want to send me letters I have a new
peel box now that you can find by
checking out this address right here I
also got a new Google Voice number that
I'm going to post down in the
description surtout leave a comment
below and let me know what you want to
see next and if you enjoy the video and
I'll see you next time stay by Lita I
got your gift what is it it's a rubber
ball pop or you have to flip it inside
out and then pop it off your thumb try
it out